let's get one thing clear as much as it
is fun to go through the various
articles on the scp archive we should
take a moment to acknowledge that it's
all fun and games the scp foundation all
the entities and objects creatures and
people places and stories related to
them are just that stories fiction
created by the authors of an online wiki
website it's all designed to be a bit of
harmless entertainment but what if it
isn't harmless what if the characters
within the world of the scp archive
somehow knew they had been created by
the scp wiki authors what would happen
if fiction was aware that it was in fact
fictional ask yourself
would you want to know if your world
your life everything you had ever seen
or known was just all fantasy if the
answer is no then you need to stop
watching this video right now but we'll
warn you just because you don't know
about something doesn't necessarily stop
it from being true still want to find
out what's going on good then you need
to hear about
scp-001 first things first which of the
various
scp-001s are we talking about anyone
looking for the earliest scp will
quickly discover that there are many
different entities and anomalies that
share that number there are a few
in-universe reasons for this one is that
all these anomalies were discovered in
the earliest days of the scp foundation
before their current numbering system
was introduced then there's the other
theories for example some have
speculated that the existence of many
different
scp-001s is an intentional misdirection
by the foundation their way of keeping
the nature of the first true scp a
closely guarded secret regardless of
what the reason is the scp-001 we're
looking at today is also known as the
database any and all information about
the database is kept secret from the
entire scp foundation apart from the
overseer council and why is it such a
secret well that's because scp-008
contains details of the very nature of
the foundation itself including its
creation but we don't mean when and how
the organization was founded or its
history we mean how it was created and
by whom in our reality confused well
allow us to explain it at first the file
for scp-001 describes a group of
humanoid entities that have the ability
to influence reality all sounds like
pretty standard bread and butter stuff
for the scp foundation right wrong these
entities are in fact the authors of the
scp wiki themselves as in the people in
the real world the reality of the scp
foundation is constantly changed by
these writers written and rewritten
whenever someone edits an article on the
scp wiki that's all fine and harmless
for us but the wiki author's impact on
their world is cause of grave concern
for the foundation as we mentioned at
the start we all know that the scp
foundation and its vast catalog of
user-generated articles on the creative
and the creepy are nothing more than a
source of fictional online entertainment
it can be fun to study the lore and the
nuances of the different scps it can be
enjoyable appreciating the creativity
and hard work that the authors put into
writing them in the case of fan fiction
independent stories original scps or
even animated videos dedicated to
explaining them it can even inspire and
fuel our own written endeavors but at
the end of the day when all is said and
done we all know that the scp foundation
is purely fictional what we don't
realize is that the foundation knows it
too containing several pieces of
information from within their own
archive the database contains everything
the foundation knows about our real
world this includes everything about the
real authors of the scp wiki and you
thought deadpool was meta you see
because the scp wiki has articles from
numerous different creative writers
chances are the details of every new
article might not always line up with
every previous one for a long time there
has been much discussion amongst devoted
scp fans regarding the canon of the
website now we don't mean a big gun that
launches metal balls when we say canon
we mean all of the events and stories
that are considered to be an official
part of the ongoing story of the scp
foundation still with us so far because
there are so many writers and articles
on the wiki the canon of the scp archive
is a bit inconsistent to say the least
and that's fine for us because we know
none of it is real it doesn't have to
all line up just as long as a good story
is being told but these inconsistencies
all the little cracks of discrepancy and
disparity are what made the foundation
themselves realize that they are truly
living in a fiction in other words
scp-001
is the scp foundation's window through
what we would experience as the fourth
wall the fourth wall is the metaphorical
barrier that separates what we know to
be real from what we know to be purely
fiction in other words it's the line
between the audience and the fiction
that they are watching the edge of the
stage or the glass of the television
screen and the scp foundation is staring
through that fourth wall looking out at
you and me
that's right it isn't just the authors
that the foundation are aware of it's
all of us according to their own
researchers the foundation has
determined that we the audience and the
writers exist in something known as the
alpha layer what on earth is an alpha
layer well imagine our reality the world
and the universe as we know it is a
slice of bread it's a strange analogy we
know but stick with us now picture the
fictional world of the scp foundation as
another slice of bread underneath ours
in between the two can be whatever you
like but the point isn't that the world
is a sandwich the point is that we exist
on a layer of reality above that of the
scp wiki and the filling is just what
keeps reality and fiction separate so as
we mentioned the foundation is aware of
any writers and readers of the scp wiki
and this does include you but the wiki
authors are the primary focus of the
database after all it's the writers who
are responsible for creating the
fictional world that the scp foundation
exists in anything that forms a part of
the narrative of that world every
article every tale every new scp that
gets published even parts of the wiki
that get taken down or rewritten all
have an impact on the foundation's
universe when the authors link their new
scps to pre-existing ones or create
connections to a group of interests like
the church of the broken god or the
global cult coalition their writing ends
up making even more of a substantial
development to the overall narrative and
all of it ends up in the database the
readers of the scp wiki on the other
hand are a smaller part of scp-001
mainly because they do not write or
publish the content found on the website
itself anything that is not specifically
set in stone by a wiki author can be
interpreted in various ways by a reader
a reader's interpretation is a powerful
concept and should not be underestimated
interpretation is the difference between
reading animal farm as a story about a
group of animals rebelling against their
human farmer and understanding it as a
satirical and political allegory for the
events leading up to the russian
revolution so what does interpretation
have to do with scp-001
the point we are getting at is that any
unwritten detail or anything that isn't
explicitly stated by a wiki author can
be changed by a reader's own imagination
this can be anything from the appearance
or personality of an scp or character to
a detail about the world of the
foundation and in the same vein if
something in one scp article contradicts
something written in another the reader
is free to choose which of them they
accept as part of the universe's true
canon each reader of the scp wiki has
their own understanding of the material
written there and inevitably comprehends
their own version of the events within
and this is something that the scp
foundation even in their world of
fiction is aware of or more specifically
the 05 council is aware of you see the
secretive overseers are the only ones
with any true knowledge of
scp-001 only they can access the
database only they know the truth the
fact that they exist in this fictional
capacity is something the overseer
council hopes to hide from the rest of
the foundation's personnel in an effort
to keep the rest of their staff from
asking too many questions the council
has told them that there is currently no
way in existence that they could
possibly contain
scp-001 but to reassure personnel the
o5s have also stated that this does not
pose any risk nor would it lead to the
total and utter destruction of their
observable fictional universe instead
the council aims to focus on what they
can control by containing any and all
information about
scp-001
nothing about the database or the truth
that it contains is to ever leave o5
command under any circumstances
whatsoever all of the information about
scp-001
or what it contains is kept in an
encrypted highly classified form at an
unknown location the key needed to
decrypt this data is a passcode split
into three parts this key is then
memorized by members of the o5 council
each memorizing a different portion of
the passcode it can only be accessed if
every member of the council unanimously
agrees that it is absolutely necessary
and even when they do decrypt the
information about scp-001
it remains for the eyes of o5 command
and strictly their eyes only any member
of the scp foundation caught leaking
data about
scp-001 is to be contained by any means
necessary this also includes if a member
of personnel attempts to get this
classified information out via espionage
psychic leakage or other devious methods
foundation researchers are even banned
from conducting any of their own
investigations into the nature of
scp-001
or the data it contains if a lower level
staff member was somehow to find out the
truth that the entire foundation is just
a fiction then that person would be at
the mercy of the most senior figure on
the o5 council it would be up to that
senior figure to decide the staff
member's fate anyone with high enough
clearance or status within the
foundation who found out about scp-001
would alternatively be given a class a
amnestic these are memory altering drugs
that the scp foundation uses to keep
information about anomalies a secret
apparently even from its own staff still
having your mind wiped has got to be
better than being killed or contained
just for realizing you're a fictional
character on an online wiki the o5
console has plans in mind for us and for
the scp wiki writers responsible for
creating them the scp wiki entry on the
database closes with a proposal a way
that the o5 council can reach out of
their fiction directly to the wiki's
authors in the real world from there
their goal is simple through memetic
kill agents the scp foundation will put
the wiki authors to sleep and then kill
them sounds pretty far-fetched doesn't
it after all when was the last time
something fictional killed someone in
our real world even more bizarre what if
this kill agent really exists the o5
council must have known for a while that
their world is fictional so they've had
plenty of time to develop a kill agent
some way of reaching us and the scp wiki
authors in the real world worse still
what if this kill agent is already out
there somewhere lurking on the scp
archive just waiting for you to find it
and if you read it how would it kill you
if you don't want to know then that's
your choice to make but if curiosity is
getting the better of you then remember
this beware scp-5999
[Music]
to continue the story go check out the
last scp
scp-5999 this is where i died and for
more information on scp-001 go check out
scp-001 which is the real zero zero one